tori
is with us in springfield missouri hi
tori welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi how are you guys doing great how can
we help
so hopefully i can make this make sense
like everyone else that calls i'm
nervous
so bear with me um basically with our
stimulus check we're you know working
the baby sets we're on baby step two
i've been the spender in our
relationship with my husband
and have done dave ish for far too long
and
finally you know stuck to the past and
really working hard to get this right
um we are on the step you know we're
paying smallest to largest obviously
and the stimulus check is going to be
for 1200 we have a car
and a credit card that are both sitting
in about eleven hundred
um we basically are trying to figure out
which
one to pay off first i kind of think i
know what you're gonna answer is gonna
be either 1100 it doesn't matter
if they're both 1100 it doesn't matter
which one do you wanna pay
and i thought maybe there'd be well the
only difference is the credit card has
interest the card
doesn't it's someone local to us that
basically was helping us out
and which one do you wanna pay off i
mean i would love to have the card paid
for
what's your household income what's your
household
i probably about thirty four thousand my
husband works can i stay home
so when are you gonna pay off the next
one if you pay off the car when you're
gonna pay off the credit card
two months um well we want to
pile as much money into as we can as
fast as we can
two months two months after the car is
paid for right
that'd be awesome yeah okay i mean can
you do that
i mean um we also have stupid tax
on a couple other things like you need
to sit down to a budget and be able to
answer the question i'm not the one that
needs to answer the question but you
need to answer it for you you don't know
you're running in circles
okay but here's the point if you can pay
that car off in two months or pay the
car off and pay the credit card off in
two months or you pay the credit card
off and pay the car off in two months
this discussion doesn't matter
okay two months from now they're both
gone right out of your life
right yeah and tori not only do you pay
it off the credit card you call it and
close it
down yes like close it down okay
now what dave's how has it been since
you used it
yesterday well
okay you've got to pay the credit card
off not the car the
wrong answer the laugh is the wrong
answer you have to pay the credit you're
not you're not in control
yeah you need to get that credit card
out of your life you can't hang out in a
bar if you got a drinking problem girl
yeah you're right so you need to cut you
cut that thing up
and close the account and pay it off
with the stimulus check and then pay the
car off in the next two months
and unsubscribe to the email places
where you shop online
they're sending you stuff it's like
crack that's pulling you into those
websites
unsubscribe get your life back today
unsubscribe from the crack
i wish it was that easy it is that easy
with money it is
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
you